let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 and see what's on people's minds
today starting with our caller from the
five-one-six-- area code who's calling
today from five one six hello yeah
that's you hey how are you David big fan
thanks um recently started listening
love love analysis I just kind of want
to kind of talk about what I thought of
something and how something else that's
going on in terms of conservative
movement how that relates to that so the
first thing I don't want to talk about
is the three kind of segments of Donald
Trump or phases you could say where we
have to have debates about how
incompetent Heon is a prize of excuse me
as a president where we have to talk
about it we have to debate reality about
what he does yes we can't even get to
the policy because we have to spend so
much time debating conservatives on what
reality is yes what a lie is and then
another thing I've been noticing is
George Conway familiar with him yes of
course Kellyanne Conway his husband
who's also an attorney a big critic of
Trump absolutely so I'm seeing more and
more conservatives I've see Joe Walsh
comes out completely anti Trump which
again I don't agree with him on policy
but I'm all for all for you know them
recognizing there is complete
incompetence in the White House and yes
there needs to be something done so I
just I don't know how prominent this
movement is obviously there's a more
educated class of conservatives that
realize there's something wrong here
well it's me and you just have to look
at the numbers you know Trump claims he
has 95 percent support from Republicans
if you look at I don't know what poll
he's looking at but what every poll I
look at says that Trump has between 78
and 80 percent support from Republicans
20% of Republicans is millions and
millions of people who are on the right
but don't approve of the job that Donald
Trump is doing and that that is not
insignificant now the question is can
you turn an election by getting those
people to vote for Democrats probably
not which is why the left just has to
get its base out we're not going to win
by arguing with the the Republic
right don't like Trump but hopefully
enough of them will stay home or
consider voting for someone else that
it'll push the election our way all
right and absolutely and just one more
no I've discussed things with personal
family members who support Trump and
most a lot of people just aren't in the
loop like they just guys that I like
Trump I have they're not really
following everything he does of course
but it's to the point where I talk to
them you know they're not very rigorous
political followers and I'll be like
I'll make a point about I'll fake names
don't believe it right like they they
just they just they have he has opened
Pandora's box with people just saying if
I don't have if I don't agree with it
I'm just gonna outright deny and I'm
here what's wrong was Dennis in the past
when you would confront a Republican
with something george w bush did and
they hadn't heard of it they actually
had to do a little bit of thinking to
try to find some way to explain it away
and explain why it's actually good or it
maybe didn't happen or whatever donald
trump has actually given sort of like
it's the opposite of a white flag it's
almost like a trump card for lack of a
better term where if someone presents
something to you that either sounds bad
or you didn't hear about it you just say
it's fake and that's it and then you can
continue and you're in your echo chamber
and filter bubble and you're none the
wiser exactly it's a perfect compound
and they just keep touting it because
it's stems from the top so that's all I
wanted to say thank you again what your
name was Michael Cruz Michael all right
Michael great to hear from you thank you
thank you
all right take care